all right i want to go through something
that's just it's so crass and it's so
um
emblematic i guess i would say
of the kind of vapid and and coarse
nature of the modern republican party um
radical republic if you say to me david
sir
who are the three sort of most
cartoonish clowns in the house of
representatives right now i would say
well it's marjorie taylor green
um it's madison cothorn and it's lauren
bober and then after that there's a lot
of candidates you know could be matt
gates louis gomer very very long list
but certainly in the top three as i hit
my microphone here and
uh almost almost damage it um lauren
bobert would certainly be in the top
three lauren bobert has been given
the hottest woman in congress award
by one of these right-wing channels
and the award misspelled her name
and included a gift card to
to red lobster
um to the to the seafood chain red
lobster
if you were to satirize
the modern republican party on a show
like saturday night live
you would create a hottest woman in
congress award misspell the recipient's
name and include a gift card to like
arby's or red lobster or something like
that is exactly what you would do
um let's let's take a look at this um if
you look at her holding the award
uh you see that her
name had been spelled lauren beaubart
with an a b-a-r-t
and then sort of corrected honestly it
looks like a sharpie to be lauren bo
bert with an e or bo bear as uh
congressman ro khanna referred to her
and there's a gift card in there and
that gift card is to red lobster and
it's in the amount of 27.43
which i guess the point there is you as
a member of congress you you violate
some ethics laws if you accept a gift
worth more than 50
so i guess that's how they came up with
uh
27.43
here is her being told by jesse kelly
who knows who these people are about the
award joining me now
the first winner of the jesse kelly show
hottest woman in congress list
congresswoman from colorado lauren
beaubert congresswoman first and
foremost before we get to all the news
of the day i want to congratulate you on
such a high achievement and hope you got
ours to i see you did get our
certificate and i want to make sure you
also got the gift card we sent along
with it
i got it
look at that jesse how's that
and
jesse i do think that 2743
is under the gift limits um but if we
check with ethics and it's over this is
coming right back to you
yes ma'am i understand that we're gonna
do the best we can to up that to 30 next
year depending on how the show does but
moving forward
the second hottest woman in congress she
was the runner-up this year aoc went on
twitter
and whined once again like she always
yeah
um
you know trump's flushing documents down
the toilet
beau bert is getting misspelled hottest
woman in congress award
if this is a simulation
someone has a very interesting sense of
humor and i think the the important
thing here is i keep going back you know
we talk about how do we engage with
these people how do you how do you talk
sense into folks
who believe
the things that people like lauren
beaubert and marjorie taylor green and
others say is it just a matter of having
a few conversations with them or
whatever
i never want to say
that people generally speaking are too
far gone
but you have to understand that there's
sort of like a culture of ignorance
and um anti-intellectualism
and a sort of pride in lacking any
sophistication or depth in one's
thinking
and you know lauren bober getting the
hottest woman award and it's been
misspelled it's it's not the be-all
end-all of reminding us about that
reality right now among this right-wing
american political movement and the fact
that this is how how unsophisticated and
anti-intellectual they are
but it's just a reminder that
this movement is so pervasive and i'm
reminded of this you know what
whenever i go to a conservative state
and all of a sudden i'm in the middle of
you know some fair or whatever the case
may be i'm reminded there's nobody who
could come here and just talk sense into
these people in any real way and that's
what gets us to
we just have to get voter turnout up we
have to just overwhelm them with numbers
because most of them are not going to be
convinced we've got to fix education so
we prevent people from becoming this
uninformed in the first place it is a
colossal task that we are faced with in
this country and this is just a little
microcosm of that that really epitomizes
how you can't distinguish between how
these right-wingers would be satirized
on skit and comedy programs and what
they actually are that there's
essentially no
daylight
between those those two things anymore
you can support the david pakman show by
supporting our sponsors and one of those
sponsors is sheath underwear
traditional underwear involves sticking
sweating the dreaded chafing sheath
underwear are boxer briefs
specifically designed to keep everything
separate cool dry and comfortable they
have a bunch of great designs options to
choose from more minimal styles their
signature geometric pattern waistband is
cool there's really something for
everybody but the most important thing
is you stay cool during the day and at
night
upping your comfort to the next level
read the reviews online sheath underwear
has been a game changer for many men
give it a try they have super fast
shipping you'll get your order in just a
few days and don't forget that you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below